hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you
oh
[Music]
how are you guys doing Stephen Crowder
is a political commentator from my
understanding he's a high school dropout
or a College Dropout or something like
that he hasn't completed his education
and from time to time he speaks about
Islam I don't know why I don't know what
he thinks he's doing I don't think
um he's qualified or trained to speak
about these topics and he speaks about
Delicate doctrinal elements theological
elements to do with religion of Islam he
mocks Muslim people he mocks Islam
itself he's done so in the past he's
never had the audacity or the
courageousness
uh to actually confront a Muslim person
let's take a look at what he said in his
most recent video and come back and
respond in kind Islam is based on the
idea that The Blessing of Abraham going
down to his you know oldest son Isaac
Ishmael was a lie so you have to believe
and this is why you have so much radical
anti-Semitism across the Muslim world if
you believe that these people who
carried the books lied and subverted the
text basically from Abraham onward of
course there's going to be some
animosity so it says well every we
believe in the Bible except not
everything else for example in Islam
this was one thing we talked about
recently where they get really mad for
example if you draw mohabbat now I'm not
saying you should just go out and Troll
and drama but what I am saying is hold
on that's more offensive than a religion
that says Jesus is not exactly who he
claimed he was right Muslims believe
that Jesus was a prophet but that he
didn't die that the body was replaced
well that sacrilegious to Christians
certainly more so than drawing a
question and again we know what Muhammad
did who was basically they're not
attacking Muslims but it's true so
Stephen Crowder who
um hitherto shall be referred to as
Stephen kawada because he is a coward
for not being able to respond or to face
the people who he claims or who he is
trying to attack with in this case
Muslim people he's just speaking to Alex
Jones I don't know that Alex Jones was
an individual who was very aware of
Islamic doctrines but he's speaking to
him and he's making a series of spurious
claims
um speculations the first one is a very
weird kind of argument in the first
place which is that Muslims believe that
the previous dispensations for us
obviously that previous disciplinations
for the Muslim people which are let's
say for example the the revelations
handed down to Moses the revelations
handed down to Jesus were changed and
therefore this brings about a kind of
hostility that we may have for that
reason to those groups now this is a
very strange kind of argument because of
course just like most people who adopt
any kind of worldview or ideological
position there are going to be things we
agree with Christianity on and with
things we reject I mean just like you as
a Christian there's going to be some
things you agree with Judaism on and
some things which you reject there's
going to be some things which you agree
with Islam on some things which we
reject I mean the fact is you believe
that uh the prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon Him is
fundamentally disingenuous I mean so
that's something you reject and you
could say you could make the argument
that that therefore you become hostile
because of it and of course your tone is
hostile anyway so I don't really see
where this is going of course we believe
that the Bible has been corrupt or
corrupted and of course there is
evidence for that Bruce Metzger wrote a
fantastic Masterpiece on this point the
corruption of the Bible uh even
Christian scholarship has moved almost
completely in that direction
um I remember reading Carl but one of
the great Scholars of Christianity in
the 20th century who practically has a
Protestant Evangelical uh even though he
tenuously kind of aligns with that group
considers the book uh the New Testament
even to be corrupt so I don't think this
is a big problem I mean if if believing
that the Bible is corrupt it's
problematic then within your own School
within Christianity itself within the
whole the house of Christianity there
are people who are going to have the
same kind of proclivity or inclination
so that's the first thing this idea that
believing that the books are corrupt
somehow is a dangerous belief Hub
creating producing kind of hostilities
um for the Muslim people the second
thing is you mentioned about well
drawing Muhammad are you kind of glossed
over that sort of Allah
you didn't make an argument there kind
of want to just mention it for some
reason and then mentioned well you
believe
we believe as the Muslim people that
Jesus Christ is not as you say who he
says he was who he says he was according
to you of course we have different
sources we don't believe that the
sources that you have are fully reliable
and we don't say that he says that he
was a God in fact you'll seldomly or
scarcely find anything except for the
you know the Gospel of John and the
writers of the Gospel of John and
especially the synoptic Bible or the
synoptic New Testament you will not find
that this uh emphasized at all the
Divinity of Jesus Christ as Christians
even says that John the Gospel of John
has I quote-unquote high christology and
of course that's something which is once
again understood in the scholarly world
of Christianity what I'm saying here is
Jesus Christ saying that he's God
himself doesn't appear to be really in
the Bible in very clear terms him saying
that I am God of worship it doesn't
clear to be in the Bible and if you are
going to say the Gospel of John has some
of those references well the Gospel of
John is a very late reference itself so
the idea that he said that about himself
is not something we even
um Grant you frankly but according to us
he didn't say that and yes it is
sacrilegious for you for us to believe
that Jesus wasn't God but it's also
sacrilegious for us for you to believe
that he is God and so the same exact
argument applies both ways if you think
about it in fact there's a verse I'm
going to recite the verses and then you
can I'm going to translate them for you
so verse in the Quran that says the
following
is
foreign
that
they ascribed or they said that Allah
has taken a son they have come with some
Preposterous thing
that the heavens and the Earth will be
split Asanda
as a result of this
and destroyed would be the mountains
destroyed would be the mountains
because of such a word
that they ascribe to al-rahman the most
merciful a son
that everything in the heavens and the
Earth comes to Allah as a slave this is
in the Quran so it's the ultimate
sacrilegious or the ultimate sacrilege
to say that Jesus is God
or the Son of God for the Muslim people
but of course despite that or
notwithstanding that fact Muslim people
are tolerant of Christians we don't
force that upon them Islam upon them as
in the Quran it says there is no
compulsion in religion chapter 2 verse
256.
the point is your arguments really don't
hold any wait I hereby challenge you to
a debate and a disco and or a discussion
or an education session I actually don't
know what to call it because frankly
you're not worthy of a debate
I'm saying that with the greatest of
respect
and I don't need to respect you because
frankly you're disrespectful but you're
not worthy of a debate but if you want
to be educated on the topic of Islam
which you've been speaking on for many
years
I can teach you the basics
I will do this as a community service
for your community and mine if you're
Gallant enough and brave enough accept
the challenge
the prophet Muhammad
told us whoever builds a mosque for
Allah Allah will build for him a similar
house in Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays there whenever someone
gives shahada in the Masjid whenever
someone learns something in the Masjid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your scale